[Musique]
qui est le top 1
qui est le concours
[Musique]
la rumba nous avons que trois accords
principal
donc
nous avons la fondamentale
[Musique]
nous avons la carte
vous avez la quinte
il y a toujours cette
[Musique]
ces trois accords de base
qui sont en fait
si on doit prendre vraiment la
simplification première c'est
la tonique et la quinte c'est à dire au
début c'est un
[Musique]
c'est ces deux accords c'est balancement
et ensuite à partir de ce désaccord on
extrapole on ajoute la carte et ça donne
mais ces trois accords forcément de
compositeur en compositeur les Congolais
ont décliné ça en
dans toutes les
postures possibles c'est à dire ça peut
être un
ça peut être
en fait c'est toujours la déclinaison de
[Musique]
si tu as l'habitude de d'écouter tes
trois accords si on t'ajoute un
quatrième accord sur l'impression que il
y a quelque chose d'anormal donc c'est
vraiment c'est simplement des
limitations que nous nous mettons
nous-mêmes par ce que nous appelons
culture
[Musique]
au son de la rumba au son de la rumba
une émission
d'aujourd'hui d'hier et du futur sur la
rumba
on ne peut pas
répertorié par exemple
le cas de ma partie du Congo
parce que comme il y a pas de document
tout n'est pas écrit d'après le
témoignage d'après beaucoup témoignages
la rumba serait une musique fortement
inspirée les rythmes africains congolais
mais des sonorités espagnoles
qui ont été déportés dans les Amériques
surtout en premier lieu
arrivé là-bas
en chantant et en dansant ils étaient en
communion avec leur terre d'origine
c'est ce qui ce qui fait que il chantait
danser tout en pleurant aussi en même
temps c'est une musique qui a son
originalité africaine qui a été
apporté dans les Caraïbes par les
esclaves noirs donc ces esclaves qui
sont partis avec cette musique
ils n'ont pas oublié donc ils l'ont
gardé
un enfant
élevé par des parents africains moi je
parlerai beaucoup plus de la rumba
africaine parce que ça concerne beaucoup
de pays
a subi l'influence
de l'Angola
plaît avant
les propos donc Togo Bénin parce que à
l'époque de la colonisation
les Belges autorisées par la musique
seul les étrangers qui venaient du PNL
du Togo et tout ça avec leur percussion
carrée tout ça elle doit faire la
musique ça vient du Congo de l'ancien
royaume du Congo c'est très simple parce
que comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure si
on suit l'évolution ça vient de l'Angola
d'une part et de l'autre ça vient de
l'Afrique du Sud donc pour
faire un ensemble total
[Musique]
il a congolaise rouge
c'est impossible de faire la musique ici
sans parti de rumba c'est impossible
de la naissance car la maman fredonne
quelques heures et les terrorise la
rumba historiquement le monde c'est
lingala français ou quoi ça vient d'où
c'est quoi la rumba d'abord pour que on
se rentre dans le bain la musique
congolaise est partie
avec
l'esclavagisme
et la musique qui s'est développée
là-bas
les esclaves qu'on avait amené l'Afrique
pour se retrouver il faisait la musique
comme ils étaient un peu déplacés à la
langue ce sont adapté avec les
instruments que tu veux tout mettre sur
place
[Musique]
cette musique est revenue
au pays donc en Afrique c'est ça
retrouver les origines
[Musique]
alors
la première crainte de colonialisme
c'est que les africains puissent séparer
les uns des autres ils avaient une
politique de cloisonnement il fallait
pas que les Congolais ou l'Angolais ça
je sais que c'est pas ça hier plus au
nord de pays comme les Ghana sont déjà
indépendants donc
il fallait empêcher tout mouvement tout
déplacement des Africains entre eux ça
c'est un de deux il faut savoir que
c'est ni d'artistes qui se fait à
Kinshasa commence à devenir un nid
dangereux au moment où les écrivains
disent les choses souvent à mon à mon
découvert les écrivains et les musiciens
ont des subtilités qui font que ils ont
de la peine à se faire prendre ils
savent qui sont soumis à une censure
terrible
plus en plus le colonialisme se voit
essayer donc de les séparer pour que
chacun aille soit sous contrôle sur le
sur l'autorité coloniale des pays qui
les colonisent avant l'indépendance
étant donné que les Belges ne laissaient
pas au congolais de faire leur musique
pour musique et
dès qu'ils ont commencé à leur laisser
faire leur musique il y a eu un artiste
qui voulait qui a fait une chanson qui
s'appelle attendez
tôt ou tard le monde changera et
attendez
vous allez voir ce que vous arrivez mais
d'une manière un peu subtile de
conscientiser les gens écouter il faut
que la situation change bon ça
évidemment
à chaque à plusieurs étapes de la vie
musicale dans notre pays il y a des
artistes qui ont osé mettre un petit
quelque chose pour
essayer d'ouvrir un petit peu
l'esprit et les populations
attendez les
qui avait prédit qui avait prédit que
nous serons toujours
pas colonisés un jour viendra nous
allons casser les chaînes de la
colonisation
[Musique]
et où est le travail dans les bateaux
quand il a dans le bateau il avait
toujours sa guitare dans un Skype en
attendant les déchargement etc les
réparations les manœuvres d'escale pour
passer son temps et jouer et les gens
venaient c'est ce que il a fait
connaître cette musique dans les coins
les plus reculés
des pays window était un grand voyageur
il voyageait par voie fluviale donc il a
subi cette influence là des gens
qu'on appelle les Bengal les pêcheurs
et des gens qu'on appelle les gens de
Mindy c'est sa région d'origine
[Musique]
vraiment de navigant qui qui chante avec
un bred nostalgie
[Musique]
je pense que
quelque chose de particulier moi
personnellement j'en ferai volontiers le
vrai fondateur de la rumba congolais en
tout cas la robe africaine dans la forme
que nous le connaissons aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec sa chanson terrible célèbre que
Marie-Louise
à l'heure il va
on disait que cette chanson allait faire
réveiller les morts et puis bon derrière
ça c'est la popularité de de Wendo on
voulait casser cette popularité parce
que c'était avant l'indépendance et
au nom de quoi un jeune africain tout
d'un coup à travers la musique devient
devient
populaire il devient symbole
[Musique]
est devenu une sorte de symbole mais
il y a eu des d'autres musiciens de la
même période qui était
vachement créatif
[Applaudissements]
enregistré avant moi nous avions
commencé à enregistrer ensemble parce
que la toute première maison
d'enregistrement des disques qui est
venu qui est venu c'est Olympia et quand
on lui a arrivé moi j'étais déjà avec
mon orchestre
je suis là
[Musique]
c'est union jazz
dans mon orchestre
ont joué sur partition
dans chacun des musiciens
savaient sur le
alors j'avais moi-même la possibilité
d'écrire la musique
et toutes mes chansons sont par écrit
alors nous parlons si jamais que il a
une chanson qu'on ne se rappelle plus à
la mélodie si on a un enseignement on
vient on joue tout de suite donc je n'ai
rien perdu même si parce que notre temps
le disque que vous voyez ici
parce que tout était cassé moi j'ai
gardé encore trois disques ici c'est par
miracle des grands des grands musiciens
comme dolvera et plus récemment des gens
comme Manaudou venez d'ailleurs
d'Afrique se sont à un moment donné
implanté à Kinshasa c'est seulement ça
qui fera était Kinshasa paraîtra comme
la capitale mais en termes d'apport il
faut savoir l'apport de dolvera c'est un
apport qui est immense il y a lui il
faut regarder sur l'autre rive sur le
fleuve Congo d'autres très grand
techniciens et tous dans cette mouvance
avec des gens qu'on entend avec
ça a été un moment très très fort de la
rumba de la musique congolaise africaine
[Musique]
feignant a été au lieu de la de la
musique de chez nous donc le vieux
feignant Émile zacha a été un mécène de
la musique et c'est là où pratiquement
je pourrais dire de Calais à Franco
comment pour tout le monde a joué là il
a fait aussi la promotion de la musique
congolaise
et pas la promotion sur le mode de la
musique d'ici également la musique des
deux rives pendant que à Kinshasa déjà
il y avait les éditions
[Musique]
d'enregistrement dans la plupart des
orchestres allaient à Kinshasa mais ici
feignant a été en haut lieu qui recevait
les orchestres venus de qui tout comme
les orchestres qui étaient ici à
Brazzaville
[Musique]
vous aviez ce qu'on appelle les
supporters les fanatiques les femmes ça
a partir du coin là-bas
du coin là-bas
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bouton là-bas
Marianne va vite
et ici c'était bon des bondé bondé de
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les les Européens le soir venez à venir
parce qu'il avait des amis européens en
fait il était situé un français le soir
on dansait le tango
la biguine ici il était de papa français
feignant ouais c'était un métier
[Musique]
donc nous sommes ici chez
Maman Georgie c'est Madame feignant et
elle m'a vu naître donc elle m'a vu tout
bébé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc j'ai baigné un peu dans ce milieu
de la musique donc je disais donc 59 à 7
ans
j'ai vu
l'orchestre bantou arriver à feignant
pour son premier concert
déjà à répéter à qui
et avec surtout dans la perspective de
l'indépendance qui s'annonçait donc je
vois qu'il a c'était une espèce de
retour au pays programmé pour aller
aussi quand même donner à vos avis le
Congo un orchestre digne de ce nom les
chansons comme Mélina et tout ça ça
c'était des chansons où quand on les
jouets vous avez le picotement les
jambes vous êtes obligés de monter sur
la piste il y avait rien à faire
mais salut
[Musique]
en France également parmelo en fait
c'était quelqu'un qui avait qui a
composé beaucoup de morceaux qui les a
plus ou moins donné à
taboulé à l'époque
[Musique]
bon ça c'est la tombe du vieux feignant
le papa feignant comme je vous l'ai dit
de la culture de notre pays
puis le conseil municipal la ville de
Brazzaville lors d'une récente session a
décidé de baptiser la rue Baca donc la
rue de où se situe le bar feignant a
décidé de
baptiser cette avenue c'est la venue
désormais Émile si on hommage à tout ce
qu'il a pu faire pour pour la musique de
notre pays
[Musique]
c'était quand même si vous voulez les
pionniers de la musique congolaise
moderne moderne donc il a dominé aussi
bien ici que le que l'autre côté c'est
polo Victoria Brazzaville et Windows
il a dit pour rendre hommage à Paulo
Kamba je vais baptiser mon groupe
Victoria peut-être que Paul Kamba a
connu un grand succès mais peut-être
qu'il est le précurseur de la rumba
moderne mais je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse lui donner toute la paternité de
ce que la rumba la rumba entre les deux
Congo je crois que c'est toujours des
sujets à
controverse quoi
[Musique]
les Belges
sachant les divisions
les politiciens comme on les appelle
ils ont
convoqué la conférence de la Table Ronde
[Musique]
le monde culturel congolais était invité
à accompagner les politiques donc c'est
dans ce cas de là qu'il faut voir
l'invitation faite à cabasser les à ses
amis d'aller se produire à Bruxelles et
cela ne pouvait être possible que parce
que l'indépendance approchait qu'elle
pointait son nez les Belges ne
s'attendaient pas
à ce que les Congolais puissent taire
rivalité
et ils se sont convenus en disant on va
se battre d'abord pour les pays et puis
nos rivalités c'est quand tu vas rentrer
chez nous
ils ont parlé comme un seul homme
sous les pulsions de Joseph
a demandé comme préalable toute
discussion que les Belges connaissent
les principes de l'indépendance
du Congo et après le reste de discussion
venaient après sans indépendant c'est
pas la peine qu'on discute
[Musique]
au tableau
Joseph
[Musique]
a créé cette chanson indépendante ciao
cette première victoire
l'indépendance
symbolise l'indépendance africaine
Joseph cabassené lorsqu'ils
chantableront indépendants Chacha il y a
toute cette
Afrique cette élite congolaise c'est les
évoluer comme on les appelait à l'époque
qui
retrouve donc cette fierté de dont je
parle souvent qui retrouve cette fierté
là et il bombe le torse et ils vont à la
rencontre du monde du monde occidental
[Musique]
des écoles qui sont créés
les musiques locales commerçant qu'il
était pourquoi ne pas faire une mesure
d'édition et commercialiser mon disque
c'est ainsi qu'il a créé les éditions
Olympio qui est devenu plus tard
s'est lancé dans cette aventure là il y
avait notre grec aussi qui a dit non il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose de
l'autre côté et c'était l'apparition de
Opika avec
Jimmy et Paul Wang et par la suite le
grand Calais avec
l'orchestre que l'on connaît
véritable est venue lorsque
Kabasele a eu l'ingéniosité de créer
l'Afrique en Jazz
c'était le premier orchestre qui a fait
le jour ici à Kinshasa
[Musique]
solide
et la famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imperfectionniste
imperfectionniste caler ne mettez pas la
moindre petite fausse note
inadmettait pas du tout c'est pour ça
que
quand la fille comme jazz se disloqué
au suicide à me donner parce qu'il
croyait il était convaincu qu'il avait
poussé son orchestre à la perfection
maximale qui pouvait je pense que grand
galet c'était avec Opika Goma pour
suivre le rythme il voulait pas se faire
de passer ils ont
[Musique]
encouragé la création de
loké jazz pratiquement avec
roitelé
Franco Viki Longomba
consort Franco c'est celui
qui a c'est l'artiste congolais
l'artiste africain qui a une
particularité
c'est le fait qu'il raconte tout haut ce
que les autres pensent tout bas
il est en fait c'est le miroir de notre
société malheureusement Franco a disparu
il a laissé un grand vide
[Musique]
je cherche sur votre petit décor
c'était l'autre 77 ans
[Musique]
j'ai commencé la musique à l'âge de 10
en 4ème
j'écrivais des petites chansons que
j'interprétais lors des premiers combien
des enfants et comme je chantais à
l'église et tout ça à 12 ans déjà ils
étaient connus
alors et vous verrez que moi je suis
passé à l'Olympie je n'ai pas joué
seulement qu'avec mon orchestre je joue
aussi avec l'orchestre
de l'Olympia c'est un chanson
la première fois
que un Africain de peau noire avec son
groupe passe à l'Olympia
ça c'est l'orchestre
[Musique]
et ça c'est dans les coulisses de
l'Olympia
[Musique]
c'était venu pour deux conseils
j'étais assaillible parfois par les
journaux Europe numéro 1
avec Pascal Bruno un grand journal
[Musique]
et ça c'est l'entrée des artistes à
l'Olympia j'avais 29 ans
et les grandes vérites
[Musique]
Johnny Hallyday Sylvie Vartan et
Mireille Mathieu
Alain Delon Charles Aznavour Claude
François et mon
ils ont organisé un grand dîner au
maximum le plus grand célèbre restaurant
de cette époque ça c'est moi
ça c'est moi l'Olympia avec
doudou qui est actuellement le patron de
l'Olympia le cousin de
décoratrice ça c'est pendant les
répétitions
venez insister au petit parce que
j'avais fait une médiatisation
si je suis un clan François dans les
coulisses de l'Olympia
cette époque là James Brown avait un
spectacle avec deux filles mais qui se
mettaient à côté de lui je n'avais pas
encore vu ça ni à la télévision ni dans
le cinéma et tout mais je me suis
imaginé et le premier spectacle des
filles la toute première fois que
jouer au spectacle c'est ce jour-là
[Musique]
des fois quand on va manger avec lui
c'est mon petit frère
on fait une chanson on dit tonton
[Musique]
moi j'ai beaucoup joué sur la morale
mais avec beaucoup d'intelligence pour
ne pas blesser la susceptibilité de
pouvoir à chaque fois que quelque chose
allait dans le sens de blesser certains
aspects du pouvoir ont été sanctionnés
[Musique]
ces trois personnes avec des
facettes différentes mais tous ont un
point commun c'est des gens
très doués et plus que tu de la moyenne
c'est à dire que ils sont vraiment
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 24 novembre 1965 pour fuyer un coup
d'état Kinshasa
Mobutu prend le pouvoir avec
les autres militaires
et c'est quelqu'un qui va donner
avec durant son règne
une autre direction importante à la
musique congolaise moderne c'est un
homme politique il ne fait pas de gaieté
de Ken il ne fait pas ça
pour faire du bénévolat
et cette période là
va profiter
aussi financièrement
au chanteur et aux musiciens congolais
mais il a beaucoup fait pour la
promotion je ne connais pas je ne
connais pas un seul musicien vedette
congolaise de la musique qui n'aille pas
été soutenu je pèse bien le mot soutenu
au vrai sens du mot matériel moral par
le président Mobutu
fait remettre ou à remis des enveloppes
à beaucoup de gens
aux gens qui faisaient la musique dites
jeune
et aux gens qui sont de la deuxième
génération pas mal d'orchestre ont pu
être gratifié des soins de musique
acheter par la présidence de la
République pour ne pas dire par le
Président de la République souvent
malade beaucoup d'artistes ont dû être
acheminés en Europe
pour être soigné au frais du président
de la République c'est vrai je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail c'est l'argent
des contribuables
c'était quand même déboursé par le
président mais c'est la condition qu'il
mettait pour aider les artistes c'est la
condition il fallait se soumettre à ses
idées politiques c'est ça que nous on
nous rapprocher tout simplement mais
sinon quelque part je crois savoir qu'il
a
enfin jusqu'à ce moment il a il a quand
même pas mal aidé les musiciens les
relations étaient très simples
c'est-à-dire je suis le chef je paye
vite à mon service un point on peut
résumer ça tout
aussi
crûment comme ça sur le plan de la
diffusion cette politique avait profité
aussi aux artistes parce qu'on a vu
taboulé venir alors l'Olympia mon but
avait mis les moyens financiers en jeu
les billets les frais d'émission tout
tout ils prenaient tout dans sa caisse
personnelle de la caisse personnelle de
la présidence
vous pouvez prendre tous les milliards
que vous voulez vous donner à n'importe
qui vous le dites voilà même il y a de
passer à l'Olympia ça marchera pas
il y a d'abord les talents la volonté
l'oeuvre la créativité de l'artiste
ensuite tout ce qui est venu après de la
part du gouvernement
congolais des rois de l'époque c'était
de moyens logistique
et ça je vous assure
[Musique]
à la prise
du pouvoir par Léo commandements
militaire avec mon bouton à sa tête
il y a un événement
qui a bouleversé les habitudes
c'était
le recours à l'authenticité sur
les stations de radio
nationale on entendait plus la musique
étrangère j'entends par la musique
étrangère la musique des Américains la
musique de français la musique de la
musique occidentale
je ne pense pas que l'authenticité
telle qu'elle Mobutu la prenait
est inspiré beaucoup de monde
simplement parce qu'il avait accompagné
d'une redoutable censure
j'ai décidé que vous allez dans cette
voie là
la meilleure façon
de
faire en sorte que les artistes ne
produisent pas c'est de les obliger à
produire la politique de l'authenticité
moi je trouve que ça a apporté quelque
chose dans la mesure que
les artistes ont ici de d'être originel
pourquoi parce que
il y en a qui critiquaient c'était du
conservatisme mais moi je trouve que
c'était quand même
revalorisé la culture sa propre culture
ça c'était une façon d'endormir le
peuple zaïrois par mon bout de ça
c'était rapporter faut pas que les gens
comprennent beaucoup de choses tous ceux
qui voulaient comprendre toutes les
têtes qui dépassaient on les coupait
donc ça c'est pas vrai le peuple qui qui
chante et qui danse non c'est pas vrai
le jeune qui sont nés dans le système il
est son nez avec l'exemple d'un système
qui ne respectait pas les gens mais par
contre au niveau de la musique il puisse
dans notre addition et ça au moins c'est
le côté fort de recours à l'authenticité
parce qu'ils évoluent rarement vers les
rap et où vers d'autres musiques mais il
va ils vont chercher ce que dans les
danses dans la plus profonde de notre
additions
[Musique]
nous nous retrouvons ici à la place des
artistes sur les ronds-point victoire
située dans les quartiers chauds des
Matongé
vous voyez là la stèle dédiée aux
artistes en général il y a des musiciens
il y a des hommes des théâtre il y a des
écrivains vous voyez des plaquettes ici
où le nom sont repris en commençant par
cabasser les Calais qui est le fondateur
de l'orchestre en jazz et vous avez
aussi docteur Nico qui fait une grande
victoire de la guitare et il y a aussi
un grand maître appelé grand maître
à côté de lui vous avez l'un des
fondateurs de l'eau que jazzy
ça a été fait pour immortaliser tous
ceux qui ont fait la grandeur de la
culture congolaise
[Musique]
contribué pour les développements de
notre musique tous les tous premiers
disques ont été édités par les Grecs ils
continuent c'est la même lancée vous
avez proposé c'est pour un Grec
en haut là il y a une terrasse et il y a
une boîte de nuit à l'intérieur
nous sommes ici devant les QG de Papa
Wemba ceux qu'on appelle communément
quartier Molokai les quartiers qu'il a
vu grandir et commencer sa musique
auprès des papas je suis le preneur de
son assistant
il m'a payé les études il y a de cela
trois ans passés j'ai étudié à la rtnt à
l'Institut Congo audiovisuel et j'ai
pris mon certificat maintenant je suis
preneur leçon quand j'étais petit on m'a
mené ici mes grands frères m'amené ici
donc j'appréciais papa
il est tous ces quartiers
donc vous avez au moins 30% déjà d'aide
même si vous ne copierez pas si c'est
que vous êtes du quartier il y a un
circuit ici il y a un deuil vraiment il
contribue à 30 à 40%. il faut quand il
joue une balle populaire il a il aura
toujours tendance à messager
il aura toujours sans être à créer des
chansons pour causer les politiciens
conseiller les politiciens conseiller la
population congolaise
quand tu es petit je veux dire ah je
vais te comprendre
dans le chaud dans le charme et dans le
costume donc il est musicien congolais
mais ces Congolais ça veut dire ouais
être dans le rumba être dans les salsa
jazz tout tout ce qui est trouvé coloré
avec le rumba
[Musique]
là je parle de début de la rumba
congolaise c'était le feu comme à Céline
qui a vraiment
initié cette robe là en
incorporant la musique afro cubaine et
la musique venant de de l'Est de
l'Afrique non non de l'ouest de
l'Afrique
et aussi la musique populaire
quand je quand je essaye de regarder mon
répertoire mon répertoire et tailler en
dents d'ici comme ça donc on y retrouve
beaucoup plus d'influence qui vient d'un
peu de partout parce que bon le monde il
évolue aussi les modes de l'évoluent et
c'est ça aussi qui fait la force de la
musique congolaise et c'est ça aussi qui
fait ma force à moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
village on a traduit ça maintenant à
cette façon là pour pour faire rester
toujours la mélodie dans le sud musical
c'est toujours bon
[Musique]
de faire souffrir quelqu'un de vous
donner une mélodie à l'envers
et ça c'est baguette ça c'est avec des
kakele cette baguette avec des cakesley
bon ça ça c'est petit sac avec
[Musique]
comme on avait dit là c'est un peu la
mode
c'est la même tempo on peut changer il y
a on peut changer notre on peut changer
la partition on peut changer un petit
peu de la cadence mais si quelqu'un
connaît Roomba
il y a déjà une grande école de musique
à Kinshasa Lina l'Institut national des
arts dont est issue un certain pépé feli
Manu le créateur du rythme cavacha
issu des Aiko
[Musique]
à ceci de particulier que c'est un de
nos plus grands musiciens dont on parle
le moins voilà ce qu'il est de
particulier il y a eu
un groupe des jeunes qui avait bénéficié
une opportunité de venir faire leurs
études en Belgique
et ces jeunes là pour se retrouver le
week-end
dans un petit cercle pour se rémunérer
un peu certains parfums du pays ils
étaient amenés à créer des cercles
culturels et des groupes c'est là où on
a qui des orchestres
C Z a I de tréma C et puis au à la fin
ces orchestre qu'on appelait de Belgique
avait trouvé aussi une manière de
composer des chansons
et une façon spéciale de chanter parce
qu'il ne chantait pas comme Franco il ne
chante pas non plus comme le faisait
grand Calais ou bien Rochereau mais ils
avaient trouvé leur ligne
aussi
[Musique]
vous allez vivre vraiment Kinshasa c'est
comment
[Musique]
ma voiture est bonne mais
le fleuve de nos ancêtres cela c'est par
rapport à l'histoire du Congo
a découvert
et comme
nos aînés
pays parce que vous avez quoi vu le jour
avant le
pays et la langue c'est le nom que Papa
Wemba
parce que comme je vous ai dit nous on
imitait beaucoup sur
ils avaient leur maison de pollution qui
avait comme langue à Yanga et comme il
en s'échauffent
aussi c'est une plante aquatique de
son village qui apporte bonheur
nous avons apporté beaucoup d'argent
concerne la jeunesse congolaise ou
africaine nous sommes des modèles
[Musique]
la complicité tout ça n'a complicité
vraiment la musique
c'est pas le cas les lots moi sur
WhatsApp
donc barrière pensait
[Musique]
je m'appelle
le grand maestro Fafa de Molokai je
chantais avec Papa Wemba pendant 17 ans
dans Viva la Musica et je te le doyen
c'est le dernier de mon local star c'est
moi qui vais rester les derniers quoi
avant que le vrai le vrai le
avant que nous moi face à des mots
lockail à ce moment-là je suis parti
pour monter une nouvelle génération
j'étais le dernier de Molokai star voilà
dans Château Rouge là il y a des
boutiques qui vend de fringues il y a
des boutiques qui vendent les produits
exotiques qui viennent de pays parce que
ici tous les Africains se rencontrent
pour pour acheter leur truc ici quand tu
marches tu peux pas faire tu vas faire
100 m sans écouter
quelques quelque part dans un restaurant
une chanson de la roue de de de de la
chanson congolaise qui est en train de
passer quoi dans dans la radio ou à la
télé ou dans une bande vidéo quoi
vraiment comme vous avez dit c'est un
quartier vraiment rumba quoi
la Belgique a eu une colonie le Congo
ce qui fait que la communauté congolaise
en Belgique
ils sont chez eux
la communauté congolaise à Paris n'est
pas chez elle ici à Châteauroux tu as
les maghrébin tu as les Maliens tu as
les Sénégalais qui sont plus français
que les Congolais
tu vois les
l'immigration de la l'ancienne Afrique
française et plus et mieux implanté ici
quand même que l'immigration congolaise
donc je ne pense pas que
Château Rouge deviendra jamais
m'attendais
[Musique]
on ne peut pas demander à un artiste à
la fois de créer et de gérer
un artiste ce n'est pas ne pas en
gestionnaire
c'est pourquoi il faut dire que
eux-mêmes et les gens qui qui
œuvrent dans ce monde puisse leur
proposer des structures administratives
de sorte que les artistes puissent
protéger l'aile création et que leur
création leur permettent de vivre
décemment leur permettre de progresser
dans la vie il y a vraiment des des
jeunes au niveau de Kinshasa qui
aujourd'hui moi je pense je me dis
toujours qui dans les droits devraient
être reconnu aussi bien par la Société
des droits d'auteurs locales
en Belgique ou la suite et d'autres et
d'autres d'ailleurs
malheureusement ces gens-là ne sont pas
mais ne sont pas signalés ne sont pas
nommés dans ces différents sociétés
parce que ils viennent
proposer leurs œuvres en les vendant
parfois même pas parfois en laissant à
titre gratuit simplement parce que sont
des jeunes gens qui veulent se faire
connaître
par le biais de ces grands noms de la
musique congolaise qui eux profitent de
tout ça pour rayonner sur le plan
continental international vous voyez sur
certains CD il y a le logo de la SACEM
ça veut dire que le producteur a payé la
SACEM pour que l'oeuvre soit
commercialisée et qu'il y ait un premier
reversement aux artistes aux auteurs
compositeurs et arrangeurs et bien
certains producteurs se permettent et
ils sont nombreux à le faire je le dis
je vais peut-être m'attirer quelques
mauvaises grâces mais tant pis ils sont
nombreux à mettre à nouveau qui est un
faux logo qui est juste pour passer au
travers des mailles du filet de la
législation française finalement le
disque n'existe pas il est pirate mais
ça arrive aux artistes les plus
importants le disque est pirate eux ont
touché de l'argent donc de réclameront
jamais rien auprès de la SACEM mais
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique pour
l'avenir c'est dramatique pour la
musique c'est dramatique
la majorité croisante des des
artistes ou des chanteurs congolais
ne savent pas écrire
la musique ils savent pas écrire
et ça c'est un handicap pour avoir des
ambitions comme
des ambitions légitimes comme on voit
par exemple pour le reggae pour les
autres musiques
[Musique]
qui jouaient la rumba congolaise
depuis le grand Calais
mettait beaucoup plus de l'importance
aux instruments à vent
ça voudrait les choses que beaucoup
n'ont pas remarqué que chez les jeunes
on ne trouve plus ces instruments ce qui
fait qu'il avait une certaine déviation
dans le Roomba pur c'est ainsi
qu'aujourd'hui avec jamais
[Musique]
ici à côté de moi vous avez
mapoko actuellement c'est le doyen d'âge
et de profession pour la section et puis
il a commencé depuis
[Musique]
je suis à la place vis-à-vis
rond-point victoire
où se trouve le bar vis-à-vis que vous
êtes en train de voir là le maestro
c'est l'endroit mythique de la rumba
congolaise
dans le temps jusqu'à présent aucun
orchestre ne pouvait se produire à
Kinshasa sans commencer par vis-à-vis et
vis-à-vis est situé au centre de la
ville de Kinshasa à la place victoire au
quartier Matongé anciennement quartier
Lanka si vous trouvez mattoria Bruxelles
le nom est dû à ce quartier où tous les
Chinois se retrouvent donc le bar
vis-à-vis se situe au centre de la ville
de Kinshasa c'est ça le bar vis-à-vis ou
franco-jouet et en haut c'est le café
Rio
une chanson de Rochereau daté de 1964
cafés Rio qui a du succès
jusqu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à présent nous allons assister à une
démonstration de la danse rumba
se
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi si hazak au Bénin avec moi
[Musique]
on a les sentiments de pouvoir exister
on a le sentiment que on est là que la
vie n'est pas si morose que elle vaut la
peine d'être vécu c'est une musique
berceuse on danse avec avec sa femme
surtout beaucoup plus sa femme
on rêve on rêve nombreux vous savez ce
que ça fait il y a de la chaleur entre
les décors
bon et puis on ne se fatigue pas on
transpire pas donc pas de différence
avec les collé-series de toutes les
façons tout ce qui est comme musique
carabine aujourd'hui tire son origine
donc des bassins du Congo
[Musique]
la musique vraiment il y a pas de
création si vous voyez bien en tout cas
pas de création vraiment il y a toujours
de la monotonie
faut aussi beaucoup créer vraiment mais
comment on crée pas les difficultés que
nous menons vraiment c'est surtout le
pirates vraiment maintenant le CD qui se
vendait comme Stéphane Le comme
d'habitude
je pleure vraiment la rumba et tant que
jeune je suis contre
la musique
le temps que j'aime derrière chez moi il
y a que les vieilles c'est moins dans ma
maison il y a que des chansons
il y a des fois mes amis même m'appelle
youssoukoumatata
oui ça va mais avec les chansons que
j'ai à la maison c'est moi c'est ça qui
me fait que je vis dans le virtuel quand
on écoute les chansons présentes des
Franco euro décalé Nico il y avait une
différence mais actuellement si vous
écoutez la sanction des JB ce sont les
mêmes thèmes même rythme même refait que
des chansons pour différencier il faut
être un quinoa quand on n'est pas qui
non on peut pas différencier les
chansons comme ça donc il joue de la
même façon
ils peuvent avoir trois conseils vous
pouvez entrer dans trois concerts c'est
la même chose
[Musique]
je valoriser la rumba
au troisième millénaire
c'est apprendre la rumba à la jeunesse
c'est-à-dire véhiculer les messages de
la rumba par la création des jeunes
groupes
tout en respectant ce que veulent les
jeunes
je crois le meilleur moyen de véhiculer
la rumba serait celle d'aller vers les
Caraïbes partout
comme ce groupe japonais que j'ai
entendu qui est en train de d'exécuter
ce groupe asiatique de faire la
promotion de la rumba mais pourquoi pas
nous-mêmes et pourquoi pas nos frères
nos cousins
de l'outre-mer
certains japonais ont voulu étudier
cette musique là c'est pourquoi certains
ont intégré des groupes
congolais à Kinshasa pour jouer
et ça a donné ce que ça a donné et
maintenant le groupe
japonais le plus emblématique c'est le
groupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comprendre la vie
philosophie philosophie c'est ça mon
Dieu philosophie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu as une belle femme tu as une
voiture qui a des amis mais
il faut demander là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'on prend la vie
la rumba
elle n'est pas fini
la rumba reviendra
bon moi qui parle je suis un numéro donc
oui c'est ça
donc
je suis en train dans la rumba j'espère
que
la
rumba reviendra de toutes les manières
en musique
[Musique]